your uh grandmother tipi hedren the the
hitchcock star
and she's she's still with us and she's
still hail and hearty
oh yeah she's 90. wow
and does she still live with the the big
cats
yes yeah she she has 13
13 or 14 lions and tigers
wow there used to be like 60 cats and
now there's just a couple
because we've got some kind of vintage
photographs of you know
when she presumably first got them and
they are
just incredible to look at uh there's oh
yeah
i mean it is what it is it's a tiger
jumping through your kitchen window
it is what it is yeah
there's a tiger in the kitchen happens
to me all the time
and then i think that's your that is
that your mom
being bitten it looks like she's about
to lose her leg oh yeah with the leg in
the mouth yes
she didn't lose the leg wow and when you
were a little girl
do you remember this were you were you
brought around the cats when you were a
little girl
yeah well i mean i was by the time i was
born they were all in huge compounds and
it was a lot safer and it wasn't
as totally psycho as it was when they
first started
you you weren't just lying bait by the
pool
mmm a baby delicious snacks
[Music]